okay so we talked about
some elements of this seem like russia
is pushing to take ukraine and that they
ultimately will be able to and it's a
matter of when not if that that's the
earlier story we did about russia
seizing its first major ukrainian city
corsair we now have to talk about the
numerous stories that have been
published
and videos that have been published so
we know that this is happening
of crying russian soldiers surrendering
all over ukraine and these are
legitimate believable stories business
insider some russian troops are
surrendering to ukrainian forces without
a fight as morale drops us defense
official says some russian troops have
been surrendering to ukrainian forces
with no fight
the senior official said the russian
military appears to be risk averse
the officials said among russia's
military are young draftees who have
never faced combat
you've seen it on the ground where units
are surrendering sometimes without a
fight and they've got a lot of these
soldiers are conscripts never been in
combat before some of whom we believe
weren't even told they were going to be
in combat so we're just seeing evidence
of a bit of risk aversion russia's
troops also struggling with fuel and
sustainment issues and we've uh we
talked about that on yesterday's bonus
show this convoy of tanks which we will
talk about again on today's bonus show
reportedly moving as as slowly as three
miles per day partially because the
troops have a lack of food and the tanks
have a lack of gas and if that's the
case obviously we would welcome that uh
that being said this official
says they will regroup they will adjust
they will change their tactics another
report captured russian soldier breaks
down in tears after being humiliated by
ukrainians a russian soldier was filmed
crying
while being humiliated by ukrainians as
the war following russia's invasion
rages on
during the video the soldier is seen
sitting some steps on some steps sobbing
with his face in his palms at the same
time a few people standing in front of
him heard swearing in ukrainian
pictures and videos showing russian
soldiers captured by ukraine have been
posted all over the place so how could
both of these things be true how could
on the one hand russia's forces be
overwhelming and taking cities and uh by
by some indications almost inevitably
ultimately going to take over ukraine
and yet there are soldiers crying well
it's because at the individual level
many of these soldiers are completely
demoralized and as the article says some
weren't told that they would be facing
combat many have never faced combat and
all of a sudden they are there and they
are just bailing at the same time
the forces are so large russian military
forces that even if you've got hundreds
of demoralized troops saying what the
hell am i doing here i want to go home
let me call my mom uh there are enough
to still continue overwhelming uh
ukrainian cities there's one video here
of uh and this there's examples of
everything this is a a surrendered
russian soldier being treated well being
given food being given drinks and
allowed to quite literally call mommy
and i'm not saying that in a pejorative
way i mean this is we're talking about
almost kids here who are just being sent
in
uh to fight a battle many of them don't
want to fight and that very few people
actually understand take a look at this
okay and i understand that the audio
alone unless uh you speak ukrainian and
or russian is not super relevant but
there is an individual here believed to
be a russian uh soldier who is drinking
uh what appears to be tea being handed
food and uh skyping skyping with his mom
and being helped to do so uh by uh
ukrainians and of course this doesn't
mean that there aren't examples of
anything you can imagine taking place
but a very interesting moment and the
question increasingly is like who really
wants to be doing this are even
are even the the russian forces who are
not
surrendering um
thrilled about this mission and um a lot
of these videos kind of tell us a lot
about
uh
not only what is going on i mean
they say a lot about the ukrainian
people and many when russian soldiers
say hey you know what i give up i don't
want to be here i don't want to do this
they are treated well uh but just about
the dynamics on the ground and um it's
it it's it's heartbreaking quite frankly
at the same time that such horrible
things are being done
at the top level by putin and others
a lot of these soldiers and this is not
different than in the united states i
mean you could say that the predatory
nature of military recruiting in the u.s
also makes victims out of a lot of these
young people uh those who got sucked
into the war in iraq and i mean listen
it's not news to most people in our
audience there's a lot of victimhood
here real victimhood and um it is uh
disturbing to see
and um
when these when these things take place
like this where everybody says hey you
know what none of us want this let's all
sort of relate to each other as humans
nice moments although unfortunately they
don't change russian policy and putin
seems determined to keep going at least
for the time being
we have so much more on today's show you
can find me on twitter at dpakman and
let me know how long you think this is
going to continue we have so much more
to discuss right after this short break